[Music]
what if law school were easy
what if law school were fun what if law
school didn't suck every year college
students from around the country come to
law school to play a game they've never
seen where no one gives them the rules
unfortunately what worked in college
doesn't work in law school law school is
graded on a curve so you were fighting
everybody else for the top spot you
don't just have to be good you have to
be better than the rest law school can
seem overwhelming it seems like there is
an infinite amount of work and an
impossibly small amount of time but law
school doesn't have to be hard when you
know the rules the goals and the
strategies everything changes law school
can be broken down the system can be
gamed when you know what to do it all
seems so effortless welcome to legal
eagle with legal eagle you'll learn
time-tested strategies to help crush law
school exams and make law school easy
work smarter not harder learn how to
crush law school with legal eagle you
can do this you can do this you can do
this with legal eagle
[Music]